Like great English style, they're much flatter around the poles, more like a potato!
My measurements!
I wanted you ordered measurements to be made, the ones I wanted.
But these are the correct ones.
Then I must call you a traitor!
Hypocrite!
A co-webler!
Theory's correct!
It's a potato precisely, Newton's right!
Oh yeah, Christian!
My dear!
I don't understand!
This is an incentive to French science!
You're a pretty, Mr. Voltaire.
Like a pear?
At all!
No.
No, Monsieur Condamine.
I understand you is correct.
The Earth is more like a...
So, the dignity of our academy is inconsistent with such emotional exuberance.
Surely, reason alone can resolve this question, reason based on research.
Therefore, with the consent of our gracious sovereign, King Louis XV, one expedition to the equator will determine the shape of the earth.
Another expedition to the North Pole will do the same.
Mmm, delicious!
They're even better when you peel them.
Anyway, is the Earth like a pear?
Or more potato-like?
More like an apple.
Well, it's round.
Like a ball, right?
Ball, yes, but not perfectly round.
Sir Isaac Newton, the great English scientist,
calculated that the rotation of the Earth
would make it bulge out at the equator.
Like this.
It never does work when...
Yeah, yeah, it works fine.
Yes, it works.
But the French astronomer, Cassini, believed the contrary.
The bulges would be at the poles.
The only way to measure the bulges is to go there.
Monsieur de Montpertuis makes measurements in Laplante,
Monsieur Condamine at the equator.
He's also offered to assist in financing the expedition
a most timely gesture: 100,000 pounds sterling.
Charles-Marie de la Condamine, Louis Godin, mathematician, Jean Godin des Audenés, his cousin, and here is Pierre Bouguer, astronomer.
Moralville, draftsman, Joseph de Jussieu, botanist, Jean Seigneur-Gay, medical doctor, Monsieur Couplet, clockmaker and mechanic, and our captain, sir.
May I present Captain Vergard, zero and fleet.
French scientists with authorization of the King of Spain, come to the town hall.
Quito, the ancient capital of Peru is here to the northwest, but the route is difficult as well as dangerous.
It would be better to travel south by boat to Gayaquil.
From there, there's a good road to Quito.
Explore the land to the equator. Quite an interesting plan.
It would be very difficult.
You take the boat then, and I'll explore the shoreline.
Alone, and then you would be the first to reach the equator. I am going with you.
Oh, you're very welcome.
Be very near the equator. I'll take a few measurements.
I can't hear you. What did you say?
I said that we're very near the equator.
You're not looking well, Mr. Booger.
I'm freezing.
Your horses.
Is it the bandit?
Explorer, mathematician, and astronomer.
I'm at your service.
You speak our language.
Yes, I do, Monsieur de la Condamine.
An Indian language and Spanish, of course.
And you know my name?
Your reputation has preceded you.
I can guide you to Quito.
But your friend looks too ill to go with us.
What can we do to help?
He should go with the others by ship.
He will go to Guayaquil.
You'll be alright aboard ship.
And I'll see you again in Quito.
Don't take any measurements now.
I-
Peter, that's what it is.
Yes, the ship sank near here.
About 50 years ago, the survivors founded the village on this river, the Esmeralda.
They are happy, look at them.
They boat and go up Esmeralda.
Now here are spectacular.
Look at those monkeys.
Mushrooms, they're enormous.
Watch it, we're being watched.
Who's that?
Latex.
They heat it and use it.
It stretches!
My dear, this waterproof sack, they're protected from moisture and humidity.
See?
Simple.
This zone.
Hmm.
This is my port.
This says as far as the boat will go.
We won't take my boat too.
They fear the Indians, they're returning home.
We do nothing to worry about.
Tomorrow morning, you'll see.
This is delicious.
Better?
Do you see? Look there!
Behind those trees!
Amigo, see? Amigo!
Now you'll look better to them!
Go higher, it will be very difficult to breathe!
Oh, this is just rope!
It's safe! They're just rebuilt it, go on!
You seen us?
Hmm, see, you mustn't look down!
Keep looking straight ahead or up!
That's better!
Right behind you!
What am I doing here?
You'll be glad you come when you see how beautiful it is!
Look at that!
Makes it all worth it, doesn't it?
Rega, rápido!
Si, amigo.
You see it.
Quito, a magnificent capital there.
Holies! Nice to see you.
Are you the French scientist?
Yeah, as we have the king's authorization.
Yeah.
Who wants to see you?
Yes, of course.
I'd better change.
I hate to take them off.
Measure the length of a great ark.
Study the curvature of the earth.
They travel so far and with so many just to prove that the earth is round.
That's the point, Your Excellency.
The earth is not round.
Why are you really here?
would it be gold perhaps or the platinum mines you're after no i understand you are no more than
english spies but we're not english sir we are french really oh just one moment you wouldn't
by chance have come here to find the inca treasure be warned i've got my eye on you all of you
you're under my jurisdiction your excellency this is my uncle one he's offered to help to
measure the earth is why you have come that's it to begin we'll need cartographic data map
Oh yes, I have one.
Splendid, that's just what we can do.
We'll check to see it's accurate.
We'll form three groups to go there, there, and there.
It's your fault.
Hasn't anybody told you never bother a llama when he drinks?
At last it appeared that the scientists could begin serious work,
but a series of misfortunes was to plague the expedition.
It's malaria the fever could kill him.
Mi nomine patrie feeling.
Arger, sejade!
Maltel sejagoal!
Distance between those windows.
Oh, my pleasure!
There's such splendid original specimens, a remarkable collection for the king.
And I will go back.
Let you down.
Sir, what is it? Is something wrong?
Have you been hurt?
I've been struck in the heart.
Sir, will you give me your daughter's hand in marriage?
Aren't you man and wife?
Well, there we are, my friends. Our work will soon be completed.
That is, I'm...
It happens, I have been offered a post of just an astronomer in Lima, in Peru.
And then I will, no doubt, go to Cadix in Spain.
i'll be on my way to make sure well and that was that my friends and this is all that's left of our
original expedition have proof the earth isn't round and now i'll make all your home i'll give
the academy my results as soon as i'm home if you like we'll do it together monsieur bouquet
of course but i will be in paris first ahead of him and my friend come in you want to go down the
amazon my son 200 years ago spaniard orellana went down that great river his voyage was terrible
The Nightmare, Leon was starved to death, attacked by wild Indians at once by an army of women!
That's right! Dangerous women!
Go over there! You see what I see?
Any of them? Back to the boats!
Dishaw!
Years ago, a priest, Father Fritz, went on an expedition also to explore the Amazon.
Here's the map he left.
His nephew, Pedro Maldonado, will go too.
Be careful! I'm told that the man who killed Dr. Signeres, Don Leon, is going to be ambushing you.
We're only three.
Why?
Once and for all, I'm rid of the French.
Hombres, wait to capture you, senor.
The men have done one lion wait on the riverbank.
The Indians will help us avoid his trap.
Beer.
Senor.
Backward pants.
Mure!
Indie machines.
Well, go on in the...
...dear.
I mean, curare is a deadly poison, but we can consume animals killed with it, and there is no danger.
We'll sleep in the boats, much more intelligent.
Dwarf monkey, a duruculi, called the Bucks.
Put out your hands, we'll see why.
Take a look at him! He spends his whole life upside down. He hardly ever moves, and when he does, he's very slow. We call him a sloth.
Can it walk? No, it crawls. Watch, I'll show you.
For lunch? No, we're using fishing. He'll show you.
The fish and we spear them.
I'm learning enough for a lifetime. I want to find out all about it.
The negro from the north is full of rotting plant matter.
The Amazon carries along a more light-colored silt. How strange! Two rivers flowing down the same riverbed.
We are coming to Manaus.
What is that stone you have?
It's a secret stone.
It's from the tribe of women warriors.
The Amazon.
That's interesting, but do these women exist?
Could exist, but then again, who knows?
Where did you get that green stone?
I haven't got a green stone. What made you think I did?
But nobody can stop you from looking for one if you want.
Maybe that way it's called an Amazon stone.
There's an arrow here.
Footprints made all around it.
Let's see.
I have demonstrated the world.
I am in Peru.
I've discovered land.
Monsieur Bouguer, on this expedition, you weren't alone.
Monsieur Lacandamine, who went with you,
traveled down the Amazon and explored unknown regions,
new lands, we could say.
He has even brought back samples of most curious substances,
and I would say this one is most amusing.
Yeah, oh, yeah, yeah, of course.
Monsieur Lacandamine was an excellent assistant,
I mean colleague, but one substance, so are you speaking up?
Oh, there are many.
The poison curare, useful in medicine,
powerful insecticides, and rubber, it stretches.
Rubber-rubber-rubber-rubber-rubber-rubber-rubber-rubber, you can see, this is it.
Oh, that.
Yeah, well, stretches, it's for, um, it's uses, it can, it's useless.
Heh, months later, at the same Academy of Sciences...
...substance in a raw state is produced in a liquid state by a tropical tree named "Hevia".
When it is processed using heat, it can be molded into any shape.
It cools and hardens, retaining that shape, as well as a high degree of elasticity, as demonstrated.
Also, rubber is totally waterproof.
Imagine how many useful objects could be made of rubber, unbreakable, plastic, and completely waterproof.
Oh, I mean new Amazonia, especially the Amazon from its source, down to the sea, 4,000 miles.
A giant of a river, 200,000 cubic meters of water every second, and deposits sediment hundreds of miles out in the ocean.
He drew very good maps of the whole area.
He studied and collected the remarkable flora and fauna, the plants and animals.
He revealed a new world that till then was totally unknown!